open-mouthed like a fish way too noisy
and full of saliva it's time for roses
and rose Hey
hi you guys i'm lauren zima here to talk
about the most Awkward kisses and
bachelor franchise history or should we
say history it's some history we'd like
to forget
that's why I've poured myself a big old
glass to get through it
by the way as we walk through dive back
into and part our lips for the most
cringeworthy kisses in bachelor history
I want to know what's the worst kiss
you've ever had tell me leave them in
the comments below tell me your stories
let's get through it together let's
therap eyes for each other personally
for me I once kissed someone and he
stuck his tongue into my mouth and then
it just sat there completely still what
was I supposed to do also was a kind of
famous person but anyway let's not talk
about it so diving right and kiss every
time you feel awkward this episode don't
because that's a lot but you know what
I'm saying do but don't just like people
should do but first ask with a kiss but
don't ask if it's gonna be awkward
communicate okay everybody communicates
so bachelor season 18 Juan Pablo the so
came in we're calling this the fish kiss
this kiss wasn't okay Juan Pablo and
Charlene everybody I only have one
question why is her mouth so open
she's like a fish gasping for air she's
like a person drowning she's like
someone disappearing into quicksand
charlene close your mouth did she need
more air what was happening and then we
do a retake I'm just not quite sure
then she needed to do a redo and a
retake I think I read you of a retake oh
god baby if you didn't get it right on
tech rehearsal the performance isn't
gonna go well okay should have called it
there Charlene Oh next up we have Jamie
Otis and Ben Flajnik
do you want to try this one more time
we're calling this JV practice now I
know that this one is very iconic in the
bachelor world and I should note so that
we are not going in order on these so
tell me what you think so Jamie and Ben
well Jamie told Ben what she thought she
thought that she made him nervous
oh you didn't Jamie not in a good way
okay you know it's like oh do I make you
nervous like bow like you like me so
much they make you nervous
no I think he was afraid nervous right
now he's freaked out
okay any kind good reason no we're gonna
play it'll be okay this kiss went down
how I'd imagine like a sporting event
goes down
I don't know sports I never played
sports of any kind but first they had to
do a team meeting but we're gonna go
mouth closed yes it was like she had to
talk it through with him like okay
here's what we're gonna do next they had
to develop a game plan okay first it's
gonna be closed and then you're gonna go
in for an open-mouth kiss once we feel
it then she's literally coaching him the
kids during the game she's on her
headset except her headset is right
there with him telling him as she's
kissing him telling him what to do next
just like you're there's an instruction
guide I don't I can't my old body is
closing in on his own it's so awkward a
sock where's my neck it disappear
because it was so awkward no no and then
he just ends it and we have to bleep
vent out and nobody blames them for that
we blame Ben for picking Courtney in the
end okay with all this sorry for that
trauma but we don't blame them for
calling it on this kiss call the game
forfeit forfeit Jamie is that the right
was the right term right guys if it it's
not whatever a red flag it was a red
flag next up we moved to Bachelorette
we're calling this one the daddy don't
Oh daddy don't do it nope nope season
eight Emily Maynard and sweet daddy Doug
yeah you guys remember Doug he was a dad
he was like real traumatized about not
being around his kids and he was not
moving forward with Emily physically the
connection was not progressing I wish
they Emily would give me like that hey
you big dummy come and give me a kiss
eyes
and then he decided to progress it while
she was trying to break up with him
[Applause]
emily has decided she's going to end
things with Doug and she's telling him
look you didn't make the move and so he
takes her ending it to be the time to
make the move it's too late Doug if you
could turn back time but you can't Doug
okay so don't kiss her and he gives her
this peck under an umbrella it's also
closed in just like the kiss was too
closed it was a no and they broke up so
have you guys ever kissed anyone and
then they broke up with you within two
minutes after that yikes Bachelorette
Season 13 Fred with Rachel Lindsay we're
calling this one the blast from the past
no kiss Yeah right I'd known Rachel
since childhood she said that meant she
wasn't attracted to him so he tried to
create attraction and that's not easy to
do any failed okay I just want to ask
you know is this a timeless you feel
that I can kiss you he asks Rachel if he
can kiss her which is polite but made
Rachel feel awkward and the best but he
interrupted itself it's going against
her and he says if I just do it I want
you to know break for kiss and he comes
back I want you to know she might feel
something that you might feel something
well you've already kissed her and I
don't think she did Fred okay you should
have that whole sense should have been
before the kiss the hope the break was
weird the pause was weird it was like a
commercial break in the middle of the
dramatic moment instead of right before
it made no sense why wouldn't you say if
I just do it kiss come back I want you
to know you might feel either way that
might feel something into your script
was wrong Fred okay
back to the drawing board Bachelorette
Season 12 Jojo Fletcher and will the
fortune teller and we're gonna call this
the should have waited for the future so
it was night one in the bachelor mansion
and we'll decided to play a fun little
game with those paper fortune-teller
things and get Jojo to kiss him I think
so but all he got was a pack because we
just started talking about 30 seconds
earlier and Jojo said and I quote maybe
that will get better and will get better
I would hope so yeah it didn't nope yeah
I don't think I was ready for the kiss
as well yeah no one was it was too soon
it was no oh god I forgot to drink every
time it was awkward
mmm I'm gonna catch up if I just do it I
will know if I feel something thanks for
that Fred
I'll just tell that to myself okay next
up Jo Jo Fletcher round 2 this time
instead of will it was Wells and we're
calling this the barely a kiss Wells as
sweet as he is he was awkward on Jo Jo
season we love him and Sarah Hyland
together now but he was awkward then he
was the last guy to kiss her
they kissed him it was like a it was the
quickest kiss I've ever seen so quick
did it happen was even on the lips let's
do a slo-mo if we can and just drink
during the slo-mo
[Music]
Wow would you guys call that a kiss did
well successfully kiss Jojo that day
next up the spit that wouldn't quit
Carly and Evan on bachelor in paradise
oh these two are together today
they have a child we are so glad they
overcame the adversity of this terrible
kiss they had to set a Guinness World
Record I think it was like the longest
kiss after eating a hot pepper or
something something but oh god was it
saliva Eve no oh I don't like the drool
this to me guys means and tell me what
you think Carly and Evan might be the
strongest relationship to ever come out
of any bachelor franchise show how do
you get past that kiss and you're still
attracted to each other and you get
married and have a child together -
Carly and Evan honestly Cheers
what do you guys think is the strongest
couple in the history of the show okay
next up another bachelor in paradise
couple Josh Murray and Amanda step
this one is awkward because of Josh's
noises we couldn't even pick a specific
kiss it's just his moaning and groaning
[Music]
No thank you I'm done okay bachelor
season 13 let's throw it back to the
original guy who picked another woman
you put your faith in Jason Mesnick and
Shannon oh my gosh I had forgotten about
this and I want to thank you guys for
reminding me of it and bringing it to
this video
Shannon is like crying her and telling
Jason she knows they have a connection
he just can't see it we have a
connection and I just want you to be
able to see that that's a scary thing to
say to someone and then she wants to go
in for the kiss but she she she has to
pick her nose first she has to pick her
nose first have you ever in your life
have you what is the grossest thing you
guys have ever done right before a kiss
no one's done this who does this
don't you wanna kiss me don't you you
wanna kiss me I'm in a full-blown viral
moment don't you wanna kiss me come on
this is this sexy and I'm crying I'm
also crying every hole on my face is
leaking thanks Stacey might want to wash
that and then after she is done with
that napkin
she's like pulled bits of napkin I think
off of her tongue and he helps her was
that the worst made napkin in the world
it's not like it was a paper napkin was
it she's like
uh-huh thank you mm-hmm
and now we make out Jake Pavelka and
Michelle qey we're calling this one the
I need more Michelle wants to kiss Jake
to just see if they have a connection
they do kiss and then she insults him
and says kind of give me something more
than that
you got to give me something more than
that harsh harsh Michelle harsh but Jake
kind of showed his true colors to us
maybe he deserved it anyway
those were all the kisses that you sure
did misses by not having seen them in
awhile we brought them back for you here
on roses and Rose a the most Awkward
kisses ever and now I want to know you
guys which one is your number one which
kiss was the number one most awkward for
you let me know in the comments below
and now I'm reliving a lot of my own
makeout trauma in my head it's brought
back some memories and so I'm entering
some more wine by the way shameless plug
/ TT online.com we told you guys we
would keep you up-to-date on all the
latest bachelor news and jordan has
posted a letter Jordan Kimball from
bachelor in paradise has posted a letter
that he says he received from Jenna
Cooper's legal team Wow Wow Wow
is this the craziest story these twos
breakup that you guys have ever seen in
bachelor franchise history
I told Jordan that I do think it is I
think it's the most wild story that
we've seen come out of the show because
it just keeps having new beats new news
beats which I as a reporter love but I
don't know what's gonna happen next and
what did happen was I interviewed Jordan
about it exclusively shameless plug
over the weekend I spent all day
Saturday getting reporting on this and
that interview is up at et online.com
Jordan says unequivocally he did not
fabricate those texts that's what Jordan
says and he says so much more including
some amazing
Jordan quotes and only Jordan can give
us thank you guys so much for watching
o --jc thank you for the hanky and we
will be back every Tuesday morning with
more episodes of roses and rosy guys we
are in the editing Bay with bay
finishing roses and rosy oh wow and I
forgot to ask what should we do for next
week's episode we just did most Awkward
kisses should we do best breakups ever
the best worst breakups ever the most
insane moments the most drunken moments
the best entrances into the mansion tell
us look at that beard look at that face
I love you so much thank you for
watching
there's more wine I'm gonna try to save
ie while drinking it's not working bye
keep going keep going you got this you
got this this is like a sport it's like
a rose a sport you got this thanks
thanks thanks coach